Trascrizione: patrizia morretti
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Nel 2002,
lavorai poco più di un anno
al Centro di Epidemiologia
della Regione Veneto.
All'epoca,
facevo un dottorato di ricerca
in Salute Pubblica
alla University
of California, a Los Angeles;
ma decisi di prendere una pausa,
e tornare in Italia.
Erano mesi produttivi,
anche se qualcuno mi chiedeva:
"Non ho ancora ben capito che lavoro fai!"
Ad un certo punto,
nel Centro Epidemiologico,
ci fu un cambiamento nella leadership.
E il nuovo direttore, un medico,
comunicò che "Le mie competenze
professionali non servivano più".
Ciaone!
Fu curiosa l'argomentazione,
poiché ancora oggi, in Italia,
non esistono Scuole di Salute Pubblica.
Ma forse anche lui non aveva
ben capito che lavoro facessi!
Oggi, però, vi parlo di una pandemia
che ha ucciso quasi
cinque milioni di persone.
Pensate a questi nomi:
ci vorrebbe quasi un mese,
a leggerli tutti!
Spesso mi sono chiesto:
potevamo salvare queste vite?
Come?
Alcuni pensano che sia
stato fatto il possibile:
altri, invece, credono che perfino
i lockdown siano stati inutili.
Chi ha ragione?
Hanno torto entrambi.
Ma non lo dico io:
lo dice l'epidemiologia,
la scienza che studia
"la distribuzione dei decessi,
e delle malattie,
a livello di popolazione."
L'epidemiologia ha una sorella,
che si chiama salute pubblica,
impegnata a "Prevenire malattie,
e prolungare la vita,
attraverso sforzi organizzati
della società."
È un po' come dire:
se l'epidemiologia fa il conto dei morti,
la salute pubblica fa in modo
che questi morti contino.
Oggi vi parlerò dei cinque errori letali,
e delle quattro azioni vitali,
nella gestione della pandemia.
Inseguire il virus, invece di anticiparlo,
è stato il primo nostro errore.
Sappiamo da anni
che "un grammo di prevenzione
equivale a un chilo di cura";
ma quando è scoppiata la pandemia,
i nostri piani pandemici non erano pronti.
L'Italia non aggiornava il suo da 14 anni!
E poi, pochi anni prima,
era stato soppresso
il Centro di Epidemiologia Nazionale.
Molti hanno descritto questa pandemia
come un "cigno nero":
un evento straordinario, imprevedibile.
Eppure, molti studiosi
ci avevano avvertiti.
Per loro, assomiglia di più
a un cigno bianco:
un evento non solo
prevedibile, ma previsto.
Il secondo errore: la disinformazione.
Abbiamo notato esperti ed esperte -
e in questo caso abbiamo raggiunto,
quasi, la parità di genere -
occupare la TV dicendo che il virus
era "poco più di un'influenza".
Poi abbiamo sentito esperti
diffondere l'idea
che questa pandemia fosse -
che i dati di mortalità
non fossero così affidabili:
sono morti "con" o"per" coronavirus?
Poi abbiamo sentito sparate:
"il virus è clinicamente morto";
"l'emergenza è finita".
Il terzo errore
è stato aver scambiato una pandemia
per un problema medico.
Ma come, non lo è forse?
Sì e no. Più no che sì.
Una pandemia è un problema
di salute pubblica.
E il virus va affrontato
sul territorio, non in ospedale.
Pensate che un bravo clinico,
che riesce a far bene il suo lavoro,
può curare le malattie di alcune persone;
ma un esperto in prevenzione
può salvare la vita
di migliaia di persone.
Il quarto errore è stato
quello che ho chiamato l'approccio
"laissez-faire" il virus.
Si è cullata l'illusione
di proteggere l'economia
senza fare i conti con la pandemia,
sacrificando vite umane
sull'altare di una falsa promessa:
l'immunità di gregge.
Ma "salute o economia"
è una falsa dicotomia.
Il modo migliore per proteggere
le attività produttive
non è lasciare andare il virus;
ma combatterlo, attraverso la prevenzione.
E l'ultimo: le iniquità sociali.
Abbiamo scambiato il SARS-CoV2
per un virus"democratico".
Ma in realtà, l'evidenza
dice l'esatto contrario:
i meno abbienti hanno maggiore rischio
di decesso, ricovero e contagio.
Inoltre, si è creata una specie
di "Apartheid" vaccinale,
dove la maggior parte dei paesi poveri
non riusciranno a immunizzare
la maggioranza della loro popolazione
prima del 2024!
Questo è un grave problema,
poiché può creare diffusione di varianti.
E sapete, il virus non riconosce
i confini geografici.
"Nessuno sarà al sicuro,
finché tutti non saranno al sicuro".
Quindi, che fare?
Premessa: i vaccini sono molto efficaci
nel ridurre mortalità e ricoveri.
Tuttavia, ciò che ha fatto
davvero la differenza,
nel salvare vite umane,
sono state quattro azioni vitali:
Testare, Tracciare, Isolare, In Tempo.
L'uso dei test di massa
è stato un caposaldo del successo
dei paesi più virtuosi,
quelli che hanno gestito
meglio la pandemia.
Non a caso hanno i più bassi indici
di mortalità al mondo.
Affrontare invece una pandemia
senza un efficace piano tamponi
è come andare in guerra
contro un nemico invisibile.
Ma testare e tracciare -
ah, tracciare, scusate.
In Italia, c'è stato il flop dell'app!
Ricordate Immuni?
Eppure, Immuni poteva essere
la "sentinella" più potente
nella lotta al virus.
Un sistema di sorveglianza epidemiologica,
con dati geo-referenziati,
è essenziale per fare che cosa?
Identificare focolai
in maniera tempestiva,
e aggredirli con interventi
preventivi localizzati.
Inoltre, è importante
isolare i contagiati.
Però, le persone che si devono isolare
vanno aiutate, anche economicamente.
Durante un'emergenza,
la solidarietà economica fa la differenza.
"Uniti stiamo in piedi, divisi cadiamo",
diceva una canzone dei Pink Floyd.
Nella caccia al virus,
la velocità è tutto.
Testare, tracciare e isolare
perdono gran parte della loro efficacia,
se non vengono fatte
in maniera tempestiva.
Pensate alla Nuova Zelanda,
che ha avuto solo 27 decessi
e ha adottato un lockdown
con un solo contagio!
"Be', la Nuova Zelanda
è un'isola", direte voi.
Sì, è un'isola No-CoVid.
Se queste azioni vitali ci permettono
di affrontare questa pandemia,
cosa possiamo fare
per prevenire la prossima?
Gli scienziati si sono mobilitati
per studiare da dove deriva
questo maledetto virus,
e l'ipotesi più accreditata
è che abbia origini "naturali".
Ma a pensarci bene, non c'è nulla
di "naturale" in questa ipotesi!
Le maggiori cause del rischio pandemico
sono di natura antropica:
il consumo di fauna selvatica;
la deforestazione;
l'industrializzazione
della produzione animale;
l'urbanizzazione;
l'esplosione demografica;
i viaggi internazionali
e il cambiamento climatico.
Ma alla base di questi fattori
c'è un sistema economico
che antepone la crescita
economica infinita,
e il mercato che si auto-regola,
a qualsiasi altro valore della società.
Questo modello di sviluppo
è una macchina delle pandemie.
I critici, visionari, di riforme radicali
di questo modello di sviluppo,
vengono tacciati di scarso realismo.
Ma i veri utopisti sono quelli
che credono di tornare alla "normalità".
Creare un nuovo equilibrio
tra persone, natura e animali
è l'antidoto più importante
contro future pandemie.
È la risposta immunitaria, e umanitaria,
da instillare in ognuno di noi.
(Applausi)